what surprises me is I was reading this
paper I went on and had a further look
at how many times what purposes it comes
up in just papers that have been
published in the last 20 or 30 years
there's an astonishing amount of
literature on rock-paper-scissors and I
think so one of the papers are the
really famous paper was where they found
this rock paper scissor stuff in nature
so there's a certain type of lizards
that use well the way that the male's
dominate one another follows a
rock-paper-scissors type game there's
the orange lizards these are the guys
they're called ultra dominant right
they've got big territories they've got
loads of females they're the big guys
right then there's the blue lizards
they're their territories much smaller
and you can tell the difference by the
way that their throats are colored
they're called side-blotched lizards so
the blue lizards have much smaller
territories and fewer females who they
guard more carefully and then the third
type of this yellow lizard they're kind
of Roma's they're called sneakers so
that it have any territory or females of
their own but they can disguise
themselves as a female and go into
attack one of the other territories so
that orange lizards you have really big
territories lots of females the sneakers
the yellow lizards can come in and steal
their females very easily but the orange
lizards can steal females from the blue
lizards who have a very small territory
obviously the big territory is a really
attractive to the female lizards so
that's kind of that the orange loses to
yellow but beats blue then the blue
lizard who lose to orange they can't the
yellow lizard has no way of attacking
their females because they're really
closely guarded and actually a yellow
lizard will turn into a blue lizard
given half the chance so the blue
lizards traditionally with this very
small loyal group of females does really
well so in that that's kind of the way
that the the sort of cyclic dominance
happens and it's ends up being well
exactly the same mathematically to a
game of rock-paper-scissors they don't
have the sort of the human psychology
shall we say of choosing to play
strategies repeatedly but because
there's this population what ends up
happening enjoy a little diagram a
triangle diagram like we had for
rock-paper-scissors lure gets beaten by
orange orange gets beaten by yellow and
yellow gets beaten by blue now you can
think of this is that the populations of
the
so let's say if you're up here this is
sort of like an acci sees within as I
can access so if you're up here the full
population is blue that all blue lizards
if you're down here they're all orange
and so on
so if you can imagine if you start off
with a high population of blue lizards
there then becomes an advantage for the
orange lizards right so the population
will kind of end up moving in this
direction and then if you have more
orange lizards it becomes an advantage
for for yellow lizards because they can
beat them and so on and you end up with
these trajectories that sort of end up
spiraling around now it depends on the
exact situation as to whether they form
closely loops or they spiral in all this
spiral outwards and but this is kind of
the dynamics that you have in the
population of lizards and it's exactly
the same as the traditional
rock-paper-scissors game
he'd play scissors do you know what do
you play what focuses as much not really
for you know since I was about 10 you
have one go yeah gonna ready on three
ready one two